[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité de cette
édition tout d'abord la course aux
cadeaux de noël
une semaine après la réouverture des
commerces avec de nouvelles normes
sanitaires
les achats de noël battent leur plein
vous allez le voir exemple à
saint-etienne dans un instant le marché
de noël en ligne
nous ne pourrons pas aller sur les
marchés cette année pour faire nos
courses
qu'à cela ne tienne dans les yvelines il
vient à vous le marché en ligne est une
nouvelle façon de consommer et puis la
crise donne des idées à certains c'est
le cas d'un vigneron de la région
girondine
il a appelé sa cuvée test qu'ovide à
boire avec modération et à voir si elle
est bonne en fin de journal nous
rendront également à monaco qui fêtait
sa fête nationale
une fête nationale un peu particulière
nous retrouvons la famille princière aux
premières loges de cette fête nationale
monégasque
voilà nous attendions tous ce moment
avec grande impatience
après la réouverture des commerces la
semaine dernière les courses de noël
battent leur plein les magasins qui
peuvent exceptionnellement ouvrir leurs
portes jusqu'à 21h exemple à
saint-etienne avec les équipes de tl7
sur place regarder
[Musique]
les jeux de société
et puis une petite caisse enregistreuse
pour jouer à la marchande à la maison
quoi ça y est le compte à rebours est
lancé
les cadeaux arrivent bas bon bah moi
pour faire tout ce qu'il faut comme pour
ce tournoi samedi le lien c'est renouer
entre les commerçants et les clients les
derniers échanges
daté d'il ya presque un mois ah oui on
est ravis on avait hâte de retrouver de
nos clients et de travailler comme on
sait le faire et non pas impliqué une
collecte à distance par téléphone par
bell c'est un vrai bonheur
les enfants sont soulagés de retrouver
les jouets mais les plus grands aussi
pensent à leur cadeau c'est le cas avec
la maroquinerie il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de cadeaux noël je crois que depuis ce
matin j'ai dû faire à peu près de 80% en
effet de cadeaux il ya quelques
anniversaires aussi qui sont passés un
peu à la trappe pendant confinement donc
les gens se rattrape mais en effet
beaucoup beaucoup de cadeaux noël
depuis ce week end une jauge d'un client
pour u m² et le respect des gestes
barrières sont donc obligatoire dans les
magasins vous le fait qu' on est pas mal
de clients qui attendent dehors
forcément par rapport à d'autres années
où on pouvait être 40 personnes en
magasin là on peut pas le gel est très
important chez nous puisque c'est vrai
que souvent les clients touche les sacs
à main ce qui est normal donc on essaye
de faire le plus attention possible
quelques files d'attentes prennent place
sur les trottoirs du centre ville
stéphanois pour les consommateurs c'est
largement compréhensible c'est comme ça
on patiente et puis c'est le plaisir de
pouvoir ressortir donc on est content
donc c'est pas grave on attendre un
petit plan fera preuve des patients à
saint-etienne les commerçants ont
l'autorisation d'ouvrir jusqu'à 21h les
soirs et aussi tous les dimanches
jusqu'au fêtes de fin d'année nous
partons dans les yvelines maintenant
vous le savez un certain nombre de
marchés de noël n'auront pas lieu
alors là bas des créatrices de saint
quentin ont trouvé une alternative
elles proposent leurs produits en ligne
via un marché de noël virtuel justin
brasier pour la chaîne tv 78 est allé à
leur rencontre
regardez ça un marché de noël virtuel
pour pallier l'absence d'exposants cette
année des créatrices de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont réunis par le biais
d'un groupe facebook pour vendre leurs
produits
une idée à l'initiative de cette
créatrice dans la mesure où tous les
marchés s'annuler les uns après les
autres il a fallu trouver un moyen de se
faire connaître de profiter un petit peu
de cette opportunité pour vendre nos
créations sur un autre biais
comme les réseaux sociaux ali la
création du groupe facebook date du 7
novembre dernier
chacune y va de sa publication pour
présenter ses créations via un stock que
je prends en photo
donc ça fait une base pour que les
clients se rend compte de ce dont il
s'agit et puis après deux options soit
en fait les clientes ont vu ce qu'ils
avaient en stock
la trousse par exemple et du coup a
décidé d'acheter celle là donc du coup
et on voit un petit message soit une
dizaine j'aime bien mais est ce que vous
l'avez dans une autre couleur à moi de
coudre en fait pour rester dans les
délais de noël voilà qui se rapproche au
total huit créatrice font partie du
marché de noël virtuel au catalogue
créations textiles peintures ou encore
zéro déchet une initiative locale dans
le domaine de la création artisanale
nous notre cible souhaitée c'est
vraiment la clientèle de proximité de
faire fonctionner le bouche à oreille et
puis de proposer des produits qui sont
plus locale que ça c'est pas possible
quoi enfin je veux dire vous dit tout de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines montigny
guyancourt voisins donc c'est vraiment
du fait-main cdu local c'est l'artisanat
le marché de noël virtuels à des
créatrices de saint quentin en yvelines
a déjà attiré plus de 700 personnes
nous partons en bretagne maintenant ou
une commune d'ille-et-vilaine fait face
à un pic et recrute pour les achats de
noël
la filiale de la poste bénéficie de
l'effet de confinement tous les détails
avec les équipes de tvr sur place à
rennes les chiffres sont impressionnants
ici 180 mille colis sont traités en
moyenne chaque jour 6 jours sur 7 30% de
colis en plus que l'an dernier à la même
période
on le sait la crise sanitaire a accéléré
le développement du e-commerce un
développement auquel était préparé le
groupe
c'est à nos investissements et on était
prêt sur les 4 5 ans qui allait arriver
là le confinement
fait changer les modes de consommation
de nos clients donc on voit que les
clients qui se sont habitués à faire du
commerce ne font pas marche arrière donc
continue donc on voit que malgré même
avec la fin du premier confinement on a
continué à avoir nos 30 % de croissance
qui devait se faire sur plusieurs années
donc en 2020 on a eu une croissance
qu'on attendait sur deux trois quatre
ans l approche des fêtes de fin d'année
la poste devrait atteindre des records
d'activité
alors pour faire face le groupe a décidé
de recruter à rennes 250 intérimaires
on doit tourner à 100 150 intérimaires
on avait encore une centaine
on a toujours une partie avec lesquels
on travaille toute l'année mais sur sur
la fin d'année on va recruter encore du
monde à raison de dix mille colis
traités par heure vers 440 destination
le site du heureux se prépare à un pic
le 15 décembre de 2 145 mille colis
traités par jour
des boîtes de noël pour les sans abri
une belle et jolie initiative l'une
amiénoise qui est née sur les réseaux
sociaux pour les fêtes de fin d'année il
suffit de remplir une boîte à chaussures
avec des produits de première nécessité
et sandra joly c'est son nom s'engage à
les récupérer pour les donner à une
association d aide aux sans abri c'est
un succès les précisions d'aller in
bollaert pour jouer au télé la chaîne de
la voix du nord marie est une habituée
des actions de solidarité et cette année
elle a décidé de participer à
l'opération des boîtes de noël pour les
sans abri elle en a déjà confectionné
deux une pour un homme et une pour une
femme et sa troisième sera destiné à un
chien je pense que ça va donner un peu
de baume au coeur à ces personnes un
petit peu de confort un peu de gaieté
d'un petit mot dedans qui fait plaisir
pour voir qu'ils sont pas oubliés
voilà un petit toutou à la réception de
la boîte on retrouve ingrid adjointe à
la mairie de longueau transformer en
points de collecte pour ses boîtes de
noël solidaire
vous avez du shampoing brosse à dents
affilées pour le show et puis quelque
chose à manger
l'idée est donc de mettre dans une boîte
à chaussures des produits de première
nécessité pour les plus démunis et après
deux semaines de mise en place le succès
est au rendez vous de voir qu'il ya
autant des landes solidarité c'est
motivant aussi il ya une entraide qui
existerait une mangue un des périodes
comme celle-ci
à l'origine de cette initiative dans la
somme sandra joly au départ elle voulait
simplement emmené avec elle quelques
amis mais très vite le groupe qu'elle a
créée sur les réseaux sociaux a pris de
l'ampleur
200 membres en deux heures et
aujourd'hui sont plus de 2000 c'est
incroyable vu l'élan que ça a pris je
pense que voilà je me dois de maintenant
d'aller au bout je me sens un peu
investi d'une mission
et du coup je suis très fier très fier
d'y participer on a décidé la de donnea
un autre sens lettres sdf est donc ce
serait pour nous en ce moment plutôt
servir données et fédéré près de 700
boîtes ont déjà été récoltées via les 12
points de collecte officiel les marottes
amiénoise et d'autres associations
prendront ensuite le relais pour la
distribution vous avez jusqu'au 6
décembre pour confectionner votre boîte
de noël et si nous donnions une deuxième
vie aux jouets de nos enfants c'est
l'esprit de ce concept innovant de
location d'une box à jouer si nécessaire
ils seront nettoyés méthodiquement par
des personnes en situation de handicap à
pechbonnieu près de toulouse
une belle façon de soutenir aussi
l'économie locale
un reportage de nos confrères de via
occitanie sur place c'est un peu noël
avant l'heure pour gérer aujourd'hui il
reçoit une nouvelle box remplie de
jouets adaptés à son âge
un concept innovant qui permet de les
échanger au bout de quelques mois des
veillées l'enfant et surtout de ne rien
jeter quand on vend des jouets qui
servent 20 ans à 0 et qui serviront
entre temps à d'autres enfants qui
auront une vie une vie complète libéraux
fait qu'un jeu qui va servir un mois et
qui va finir dans un grenier qui sortir
un top 10 dans le plus tard pour finir
dans une poubelle que la dernière box ça
vous a plu et à +10 l'idée donc de
redonner vie aux jouets en bois ou en
tissu grâce à ces boks allant de la
naissance jusqu'à quatre ans et qui
évoluent en fonction des besoins de
l'enfant ce qui nous anime c'est le côté
famille enfance mais aussi côté écologie
du projet puisqu'il ya un gaspillage
énorme dans l'industrie du jouet est un
jouet que jeter chaque seconde on a pas
de filière de recyclage
il ya énormément aussi de cadeaux qui se
font et c'est parfois difficile de faire
respecter ses choix
donc voilà la boxe à cela c'est vraiment
une box pour les enfants avec les jouets
mais aussi pour les parents qui peuvent
y lire les fiches pédagogiques et qui
peuvent se décharger de toute la partie
et recherche de jouer à chat avant
chaque envoi
les jouets sont examinés réparer si
besoin est nettoyé méthodiquement par
des personnes en situation de handicap à
l'établissement de service d aide par le
travail de pechbonnieu près de toulouse
une belle façon de soutenir l'économie
locale et de favoriser la réinsertion
professionnelle on n'a que
de jouer on a une participation à une
activité
je dirais solidaire on est dans une
démarche éco responsable et donc pour
les travailleurs c'est aussi important
comme pour nous d'être dans inscrits
dans ce qui est attendu d'un sucre vers
quoi doit les notre société à l'heure
actuelle une nouvelle box tribut pour
les familles nombreuses est maintenant
disponible
comptez environ 40 euros par box et par
mois à commander sur internet
de quoi faire rêver vos petits anges
pour les fêtes une belle initiative
maintenant qui nous vient des vosges
pour rompre la solitude des personnes
âgées pendant ces confinement est bien
le maire de la ville hindi ou a eu
l'idée avec son équipe municipale de
leur prêter des tablettes numériques
pour faire des visioconférences avec
leurs proches le village a acheté trois
tablettes les habitants volontaires ont
tous plus de 80 ans
comme m'a dit devenue une geek sur le
tard et le voir un véritable bonheur
pour elle
un reportage de nos confrères de via
vosges sur place
après je me dis comment ça va je fais le
tour
oui je vais voir si tout va bien lorsque
le maire du village de la vigne du
auprès de bruyère rend visite à ma 10 86
ans et par infection mais aussi pour
s'assurer qu'elles maîtrisent la
tablette que la commune lui a confié
pour faire des visioconférences avec sa
famille pendant le confinement mahdi
hésitent encore un peu mais elle a
vaincu ses peurs et en quelques clics
elle appelle tous les jours sa fille
alors bah oui ils vont bien au fait
comme les jeunes maintenant à un autre
âge ont rajeuni
je ne savais pas ce que c'était ni rien
du tout puis comme moi j'ai jamais été
beaucoup
nu à l'école mariage et jamais on
n'avait pas à l'école daltin alors donc
il nous fallait une tablette qui soit
facile d'utilisation accessible partout
sur le village qui est du réseau parce
que principe de cette tablette
c'est comme un téléphone ca fonctionne
avec une carte sim le maire a trouvé une
façon originale de rompre la solitude il
s'est inspiré des tablettes utilisés
dans les ehpad et pour 500 euros la
commune en acheter trois confiés à des
volontaires jusque là m'a dit téléphone
est assez proche mais les voir c'est
beaucoup mieux
j'appelle des poils mon fils philippe à
la épi monique l'idée pour les petits
enfants aussi je suis un futur et le
maire est allé plus loin il a mis en
place des astreintes avec d'autres élus
eelv du conseil municipal on a créé
trois groupes le groupe qui donne des
appels téléphoniques aux personnes âgées
un groupe qu'il fait les courses et puis
éventuellement un autre groupe de
conseillers municipaux qui peuvent faire
du petit dépannage une chaudière qui
s'arrêtent woods à la fin du confinement
la commune récupérera les tablettes pour
des cours d'informatique m'a dit elle
est devenue une geek sur le tard et
selon le maire un autre villageois de 92
ans voudrait bien s'y mettre
rappelle toi aller bébé c'est la
rubrique écorégions dans ce gîte et
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
un fléau lutter contre la prolifération
de bouteilles en plastique véritable
catastrophe pour notre environnement
l'effet picot bonjour cela nous concerne
tous mais une pme à développer de son
côté une solution originale avec succès
bon j'en sais rien bonjour à tous
le saviez vous chaque jour en france
nous jetons 25 millions de bouteilles
d'eau en plastique et un peu plus de la
moitié seulement est recyclé le meilleur
déchet reste le zéro déchet vous me
direz c'est le défi de la pme kastali
elle a mis au point des fontaines design
qui permettent
micro filtrée et purifiée l'eau du
robinet essentiellement installés dans
les entreprises les cafés les
restaurants les hôtels les fontaines
kastali permet d'obtenir de l'eau plate
ou gazeuse et ont permis en 2019
d'économiser 24 millions de bouteilles
24 millions de bouteilles qui ne sont
pas allés à la poubelle car le principe
de caste aller au delà de l'eau micro
filtré est bien c'est d'avoir sa propre
bouteille en verre personnalisable et le
concept marche plus de 2500 fontaines
installées utilisé par deux millions de
consommateurs et un objectif affiché
atteindre les 100 millions de bouteilles
plastiques économise en 2021
thibault la marque a eu cette idée
déprimé par l'omniprésence des
bouteilles d'eau en plastique qui
détruisent notre planète c'est lui qui a
développé ses fontaines nouvelle
génération et pendant le premier
confinement castelli à lever 13,5
millions d'euros pour assurer son
développement vers les particuliers
va-t-on vers la fin des bouteilles en
plastique c'est l' affaire de tous merci
michel picaud rendez vous dans un
prochain jt des territoires bien sûr
nous nous rendons en corse maintenant où
l'intercommunalité de calvi balagne a
lancé cette semaine une initiative de
réduction de déchets elle le présentait
pour la première fois l'école maternelle
de cars de l'ue de calvi avec la mise en
place d'un composteur partager voici
tous les détails avec ce reportage
devient pas aisé sur place en corse
cette semaine européenne de réduction
des déchets qui a lieu tous les ans
était maintenu on a décidé de maintenir
nous aussi nos actions dans la mesure du
possible
là on installe un composteur partagé
pour apprendre aux enfants le devenir en
fait de leur bio déchets comment on fait
du compost et comment leur peau de
banane par exemple peut se transformer
en terro on a aussi d'autres actions
comme ici commence la mer où on va poser
des plaques sur six bouches d'égout de
la commune de calvi c'est bouche d'égout
seront destinés aux passants
l'inscription qu'on va poser dessus sera
ici commence la mer pour dire aux gens
mais voilà si vous jetez dans une bouche
d'égout à mégots de cigarette un déchet
quelconque il va finir un moment donné
en mer et vu l'état de nos océans
ces dernières années c'est parce qu'il
ya de ce qu'il ya de mieux le tri c'est
la faire des petits et grands exactement
tous les publics doivent être
sensibilisés
et tout le monde est concerné la crise
des déchets est encore bien présente
donc
voilà on essaye en tout cas de toucher
vraiment de sensibiliser tout le monde
quels sont les outils pour expliquer le
compostage aux enfants à commencer par
loterie à dire exactement ce qu'il
fallait mais dans les poubelles jaunes
ce qu'il fallait mettre dans les
poubelles grises ou noires les poubelles
bleues là on est en train de franchir un
autre cap puisque on installe un
composteur à l'école car dès les enfants
apprennent davantage lorsqu'ils sont
acteurs une action qui mine et quand on
jette les déchets la cantine on leur
indique où les jeter et petit à petit se
rendent compte que leurs actions
aboutissent à un résultat qui est le
compost on peut espérer justement quand
leur apprenant tout petit ces gestes là
on puisse dans le futur à voir des
adultes responsables
c'est c'est de leur planète qu'on est en
train de parler la nôtre mais surtout de
la leur et deux lors des futures
générations et il est vraiment très
important justement de les sensibiliser
dès le plus jeune âge
voilà tout ce qu'ils vont apprendre là
ils n'oublieront pas nous partons au mot
maintenant pour l'improbable aventures
d'une écurie automobile sarthoise
l'écurie zoch une écurie qui se rendait
au portugal pour un meeting
quand le camion qui transportait les
trois voitures après tout simplement feu
sur l'autoroute dont tout a brûlé mais
l'équipe a quand même réussi à remporter
la course et le championnat
une histoire racontée par les équipes de
lmtv sartre sur place nos confrères et à
15 jours en descendant à portimao
j'ai à mes camions et demi ensemble
kaboul et avec trois voitures à
l'intérieur il y avait une ligier et
donc une voiture comme celle ci vous en
avez deux ici un incroyable coup du sort
pour cette écurie sarthoise trois
voitures qui partent en fumée
à deux jours d'une course décisive pour
le titre du championnat ligier js cov
très judicieux talent trois cent mille
euros
pour les cas où c'est un travail d'une
saison qui réduit ensemble donc c'est
compliqué le sentiment il est compliqué
on est tous un petit peu près sous choc
c'est ça pourtant l'espoir revient très
vite deux amis propose de descendre une
autre voiture jusqu à portimao portugal
1800 kilomètres à faire le plus vite
possible pour pouvoir espérer participer
aux essais quand on descendre le
lendemain matin en disant qu'à écouter
les gars on a peut-être une solution et
on va nous descendre une voiture pour
pouvoir continuer le championnat
là il ya beaucoup d'espoir qui renaît et
puise au moment de la course incroyable
revirement de situation
zo je remporte la première place de
l'étape et du championnat on a engagé
donc trois voitures sur ce dernier
meeting et ont fait 1er 2e 3e c'était
une vraie explosion de joie quand le
drapeau à damier cbc surnom quoi un coup
de malchance qui finit bien donc
l'assurance devrait couvrir la plupart
des dommages ne reste plus qu'à préparer
la prochaine saison et a racheté trois
voitures
nous ne pouvions pas passer à côté de
cette initiative amusante d'un vigneron
girondins tournées par nos confrères de
tele7 à bordeaux la crise que nous
vivons à donner à ce viticulteur une
idée il a décidé de surfer avec humour
sur cette crise
cette pandémie pour rendre l'un de ces
vins beaucoup plus attractif
son nom le test qu'aux vide à consommer
bien sûr avec modération regardez ce
reportage
les équipes de télé 7 face à la demande
jean christophe moreau ray étiquettes
des flacons de son test qu'aux vielleux
se trouve en pharmacie mais chez
certains cavistes
il prend la forme d'une bouteille de 75
centilitres d'une cuvée bio éphémère de
la chapelle bérard situe à saint quentin
de caplong région le mode d'emploi est
simple il s'appuie sur l'un des
symptômes de la cop vide
la perte de droits et de goût si après
s'être servi un verre de ce vin le
consommateur ne ressens rien ni au nez
et en bouche alors il est touché par le
virus
cette idée à l'humour décalé est née
dans la tête de ce vigneron et de ses
collaborateurs il y a quelques semaines
avec un constat les vins de bordeaux
doivent être plus attractif pour conclu
de nouveaux consommateurs et surmonter
la crise commerciale qu'il traverse
et pour ce vigneron la transgression est
certainement l'une des méthodes les plus
efficaces pour y arriver alors la
question c'est de savoir si on fait de
la transgression pour de la transation
ou si on fait quelque chose qui sort des
sentiers battus pour être en phase avec
l'attenté des clients
c'est une manière d'aborder le monde du
vin sous un angle de tout à fait nouveau
et je trouve ça très rafraîchissant
d'ailleurs avec ce test qu'aux but jean
christophe moreau dans n'est pas à son
premier coup d'essai et en a même fait
son fond de commerce
depuis quatre ans maintenant ils
appliquent ce concept à toute une partie
de sa gamme de vins souvent dans les
danses et visuel là on a des produits
qui sont tous dans l'esbrouffe
l'idée s'est jamais compliqué de vendre
la première bouteille c'est la deuxième
qui nous intéresse c'est la deuxième
elle se fait le second chat se fait
toujours par par le contenu de la
bouteille pour ce vigneron sécu à
l'étiquette transgressive n'ont pas
d'autre but que d'attirer de nouveaux
consommateurs en collant à leurs
attentes
il s'agit ensuite de les aiguiller vers
des vins puis élaborer plus complexe en
attendant la cuvette est qu vide a été
tirée 3800 bouteille elle s'est vendue
en france mais aussi en belgique
face au succès commercial rencontré jean
christophe moreau envisage de créer une
seconde cuvée test covit version 2.0
dans les semaines à venir
elle devrait mettre à l'honneur cette
fois ci un vain mot de ces pages
je vous le disais dans les titres les
monégasques n'ont pas pu se rendre sur
la place du palais cette année et
manifester leur affection à la famille
princière à l'occasion des fêtes
nationales à cause de la crise du
coronavirus bien sûr tout de même un
résumé de cette fête nationale un peu
particulière avec christine d'atomes l2
monaco as faux sur place pour ouvrir les
festivités le souverain accompagné de
son épouse et la princesse charlène et
d'une partie des membres de sa famille
et assister à une messe d'action de
grâce à la cathédrale de monaco
cette année seulement 400 personnes
distancié masqué pouvaient participer à
cette et des hommes présidée par
monseigneur dominique marie david il
s'agissait
hier de la première fête nationale pour
l'archevêque de monaco
sachez que je suis personnellement
honoré profondément heureux et toucher
de vivre pour la première fois cet
événement
à noter également que le nouveau
ministre d'état pierre dartout
participer lui aussi pour la première
fois à cette fête nationale comme les
années précédentes la prise d'armes a
été donné dans la cour d'honneur du
palais princier
après que l'hymne national de la
principauté et retentit le prince
souverain a passé en revue les troupes
et a salué l'étendard sous le regard
bienveillant de la princesse charlène et
de ses enfants
pour l'occasion le petit prince jacques
était habillé comme son papa en tenue de
carabinier
le prince albert ii a remis les galons
militaires de la force publique promu en
2020 à onze sapeurs-pompiers et 16
carabiniers avant de remettre les
insignes de chevalier dans l'ordre de
saint charles dans ce contexte
particulier de crise sanitaire le prince
albert ii a ensuite remis l'ordre de
grimaldi promotion qu'ovide 19 à la
croix rouge monégasque en décorant son
drapeau treize membres du personnel du
palais princier ont ensuite reçu des
mains du prince souverain la médaille
d'honneur où tu travailles pour services
rendus
une cérémonie qui s'est achevée avec la
garde à l'étendard du prince souverain
un porte étendard et sa garde composée
de cinq carabiniers dont trois en tenue
de papa l'un marquer les 150 ans de la
compagnie des carabiniers du prince avec
l'arrivée des militaires de l'armée
pontificales de rome
une commémoration qui marque également
les quinze années de règne du prince
albert ii et puis je signale cette
édition spéciale du magazine le point
spécial marseille cette semaine une
édition encore donné par audrey emery et
jérôme cordelier le rédacteur en chef du
service politique du point avec
notamment un papier politique sur le
dernier coup
de jean claude gaudin le dernier coup
politique de l'ancien maire de marseille
mais également qui dirige vraiment
marseille avec cette nouvelle équipe
municipale des articles également plus
proche de l'art de vivre des bouches du
rhône avec 5 reste au click and collect
de la capitale des bouches du rhône et
puis pas de printemps pour le printemps
vous le verrez donc dans cette édition
spéciale marseille du magazine le point
cette semaine voit la fin du grand jt de
territoire merci de l'avoir suivi sur
vos chaînes régionales et locales et sur
tv5 monde et rendez vous évidemment dans
une prochaine édition avoir à tous merci
[Musique]